This lecture is a continued discussion
of probabilistic topic models.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue discussing probabilistic
models, we are going to talk about a very
simple case where we are interested in
just mining one topic from one
document.
So in this simple setup
we are interested in analyzing one
document and trying to
discover just one topic.
So this is the simplest case of topic
modeling.
The input now no longer has K, which is
the number of topics because we know
there is only one topic.
And the collection has only one
document also.
In the output we also no longer have
coverage because we assumed that the
document covers this topic 100%.
So the main goal is just to discover
the word probabilities for this
single topic, as shown here.
As always, when we think about using a
generative model to solve such a problem,
we'll start with thinking about what
kind of data we're going to model or
from what perspective we're going to
model the data or data representation.
And then we're going to design a
specific model for the generation of
the data from our perspective.
Where our perspective just means we
want to take a particular angle of
looking at the data so that the model
would have the right parameters for
discovering the knowledge that we want,
and then we'll be thinking about the
likelihood function or write down the
library function to capture more
formally how likely a data point will
be obtained from this model.
And the likelihood function will have
some parameters in the function and
then we are usually interested in
estimating those parameters, for
example by maximizing the likelihood
which would lead to maximum likelihood
estimator and these estimated
parameters would then become the output
of the mining algorithm.
Which means we'll take the estimated
parameters as a knowledge that we
discover from the text.
So let's look at these steps for this
very simple case.
Later, we'll look at this
procedure for some more complicated
cases.
So our data in this case is just the
document which is a sequence of words.
Each word here is denoted by X sub I.
Our model is a unigram language model,
a word distribution that we hope to
denote a topic and that's our goal.
So we will have as many parameters as
many words in our vocabulary,
in this case M.
And for convenience we're going to use
theta sub I to denote the
probability of word W sub I.
And obviously these thetas of i's
would sum to one.
Now, what does the likelihood function
look like?
This is just the probability of
generating this whole document
given such a model. Because we assume
the independence in generating each
word,
so the probability of the word the
document would be just a product of the
probability of each word.
And since some word might have repeated
occurrences, so we can also rewrite
this product in a different form.
So in this line we have rewritten the
formula into a product over all the
unique words in the vocabulary,
W sub one through the W sub M.
Now this is different from the previous
line where the product is over
different positions of words in the
document.
Now when we do this transformation,
we then would need to introduce a count
function here.
This denotes the count of word one in
document.
And similarly, this is the count of
words of M in the document. Because
these words might have repeated
occurrences.
You can also see if a word did not occur
in the document, it would have a zero
count and therefore that
corresponding term will disappear.
So this is a very useful form of
writing down the likelihood function
that we will often use later.
So I want you to pay attention to this.
Just get familiar with this notation.
It's just to change the
product over all the different words in
the vocabulary.
So in the end, of course we'll use theta
sub I to express this likelihood
function and it would look like this.
Next, we're going to find the theta
values,
or probabilities of these words that
would maximize this likelihood
function.
So now let's take a look at the maximum
likelihood estimate problem more
closely.
This line is copied from the previous
slide.
It's just our likelihood function.
So our goal is to maximize this likelihood
function.
We will find it often easy to
maximize the log likelihood instead of
the original likelihood and this is
purely for mathematical convenience,
because after the logarithm
transformation,
our function will become a sum instead
of a product.
And we also have constraints
over these probabilities.
The sum makes it easier to take
derivative, which is often needed for
finding the optimal solution of this
function.
So please take a look at this sum
again here and this is a form of
function that you often see later also in
more general topic models.
So it's a sum over all the words in the
vocabulary and inside the sum there is
a count of words in the document.
And this is multiplied by the logarithm
of the probability.
So let's see how we can solve this
problem.
Now at this point the problem is purely
a mathematical problem, because we're
going to just to find the optimal
solution of a constrained maximization
problem.
The objective function is the
likelihood function, and the constraint
is that all these probabilities must
sum to one.
So one way to solve the problem is to
use Lagrange multiplier approach.
Now this content is beyond the scope of
this course.
But since Lagrange multiplier is very
useful approach, I also would like to
just give a brief introduction to this
for those of you who are interested.
So in this approach we will construct a
Lagrange function here.
And this function would combine our
objective function with another term
that encodes our constraints.
And we introduce Lagrange multiplier
here, Lambda.
So it's additional parameter.
Now the idea of this approach is to just
turn the constrained optimization
into, in some sense, unconstrained
optimizing problem.
So now we're just interested in
optimizing this Lagrange function.
As you may recall from calculus, an
optimal point would be achieved when
the derivative is set to 0.
This is a necessary condition.
It's not sufficient though, so.
If we do that, you will see the partial
derivative with respect to theta i here
is equal to this.
And this part comes from the
derivative of the logarithm function.
And this Lambda is simply taken from
here.
And when we set it to zero, we can
easily see theta sub i is related to
Lambda in this way.
Since we know all the theta I's must sum
to one, we can plug this into this
constraint here, and this will allow us
to solve for Lambda.
And this is
just negative sum of all the counts and
this further allows us to then solve
optimization problem.
Eventually to find the optimal setting
for Theta Sub I.
And if you look at this formula, it
turns out that it's actually very
intuitive because this is just the
normalized count of these words by
the document length, which is also a
sum of all the counts of words in the
document.
So after all this math, after all, we
have just obtained something that's
very intuitive, and
this will be just our intuition where
we want to maximize the
theta by assigning as much
probability mass as possible to all the
observed words here.
And you might also notice that this is
the general result of maximum
likelihood estimator.
In general, the estimate would be to
normalize count and it's just
sometimes the counts have to be done in
a particular way, as you will also see
later.
So this is basically an analytical
solution to our optimization problem.
In general, though, when the likelihood
function is very complicated, we're not
going to be able to solve the
optimization problem by having a closed
form formula.
Instead, we have to use some numerical
algorithms, and we're going to see such
cases later also.
So if you imagine what would we get if
we use such a maximum likelihood estimator
to estimate one topic for a single
document D here, let's imagine this
document is a text mining paper.
Now what you might see is something
that looks like this.
On the top you will see the high
probability words tend to be those very
common words, often functional words in
English, and this will be followed by
some content words that really
characterized the topic
well like text, mining etc and then
in the end you also see various more
probabilities of words
that are not really related to the
topic, but they might be externally
mentioned in the document.
As a topic representation, you will see
this is not ideal, right?
The because of the high probability
words are functional words
they are not really characterizing the
topic.
So one question is how can we get rid
of such common words?
Now this is a topic of the next lecture.
We're going to talk about how to use
probabilistic models to somehow get rid
of these common words.